My name's Kevin Adams.
I am a technical instructor
for the United States Army,
and I'm a part time bladesmith.
My grandfather and my father
worked in the same steel mill
together, so their influence
enabled me to be able to pick
up the trade fairly quickly.
My name is Aric Fontaine
and I have been bladesmithing
now for almost 10 years.
I stay with it because it's
a comfort place for me.
And just being able
to create something,
it's a really cool experience.
Well, Kevin, Aric,
congratulations.
You guys are both moving
forward into round three
of our competition,
where we will
be sending you home to work on
an iconic weapon from history.
And that weapon is the
serrated Tegha sword.
Lord have mercy.
NARRATOR: Originating in
India in the 18th century,
this intimidating
curved sword was known
to be a great executioner.
Its unique design features a
nearly three foot long blade
with a split tip
and serrated edges
that could easily behead a man.
Its two pronged tip
is a powerful symbol
throughout the Islamic
world and is inspired
by the legendary
sword Zulfiqar, which
is believed to be descended
from the prophet Muhammad.
You guys have a
lot of parameters
to follow, so pay attention.
You guys need to
make a blade that
is between 24 and 26 inches.
That curve depth needs to be
no less than 3 and 1/2 inches.
You need to have a split at the
tip that goes down between 10
and 11 inches, followed
by a puncture hole
at the end of that split.
The curved edge and the
back edge of the split
need to be serrated
and sharpened.
Now you guys need
to have a Khanda
style hilt with a tail pommel.
I have never seen anything
like this in my life.
It's got these crazy curves.
It's serrated everywhere.
It just combines so many
different skill sets.
It's going to be a
challenge to create.
You have four days
in your home forges.
We'll see you then.
Good luck.
Good luck to you as well.
I'm back in my home forge
and I'm ready to start
working on this serrated Tegha.
The length and the
curvature of the blade
is something I've never
had to deal with before.
Start getting my
blade forged to shape.
Looks like a hockey stick.
So now I got to shape the tip.
That's concerning for me
because the only thing I have
to cut metal with is a grinder.
You don't have a lot of control.
Not pretty, but it's a start.
Getting ready to
quench the blade.
She's hard.
The heat treat went good.
There's a lot of work to do
yet, but it's a good start.
The plan for today is make that
cut from the hole to the tip.
This is a butt
puckering moment for me.
If this doesn't work,
I'm in deep trouble.
Oh man, that is way
too thin up there.
What can you do?
Now my biggest challenge
is the handle and guard.
There's a lot of
moving parts with it.
Even though it's a lot of hard
work and there's frustration,
I had fun.
That's why we do this craft.
It's good to be back
here in my own domain.
I'm going to be building
a serrated Tegha sword.
I've never done anything
even remotely close to it,
so it's going to be
an exciting build.
I got the rough shape on my tip.
I'm going to take
it over to the vise
and I'm going to start
splitting it down.
While my steel is
heating, I might as well
be doing something else.
This is going to be the guard.
I grab the metal that
I'm going to be using
for my pommel and the guard.
I start forging those into
the proper dimensions.
Right now, I feel like
I'm in pretty good shape.
Time to quench.
It's actually not bad.
It's time to
assemble this thing.
All right.
That's a little
better, less worse.
Now that I have
a finished blade,
I have a piece of roast beef.
That is a nice, clean
cut right there.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
Let's find out what
kind of lethal damage
your serrated Tegha will do.
Kevin, you're up first.
You ready?
Ready as I'll ever be.
DOUG: Let's do this.
As Doug is getting
ready to do the kill test,
I can feel my heart
rate is increasing.
Is there a flaw
in there anywhere?
Did I heat treat correct?
So I'm feeling not
that confident.
[music playing]
All right.
Kevin, let's talk about
your serrated Tegha here.
First up, the
serrations you have here
are indeed very sharp.
You can feel every cut.
Now your handle
construction is smooth.
A little bit on the
wider side of this
handle, but it wasn't an issue
in controlling your weapon.
Overall, sir, your
weapon will kill.
All right, Aric.
Ready to take a look?
I'm ready.
Let's do it.
DOUG: All right.
Kevin's blade performed
absolutely phenomenal.
I mean, he cut the
dummy's head off.
I've got to perform at least
at that level to even have
a chance at winning this thing.
[music playing]
All right, Aric.
The serrations on
your sword are sharp.
When I ripped through the
shoulder, it cut easily.
Now your sword is much lighter.
It tapers before it
gets to the bend,
making the sword easy
to swing one handed.
Overall, sir, your
weapon, it will kill.
Awesome.
All right, gentlemen,
time for the strength test.
Now to test the strength
and overall construction
of your blades, I will be taking
them and smashing these pots.
Now remember, this is not
about how well your blades hold
up through this punishment.
Kevin, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
Kevin, your handle,
it's kind of fat.
But your distance, your
scale with your guard
is great for me.
As far as your
blade goes, I mean,
you've taken some
pretty big hits
and lost a lot of the
tips of your serrations.
The blade is in one piece.
It's still solid.
Nothing loosened up.
Well done.
Thank you.
All right.
Aric, ready to get ugly?
Tear it up.
[music playing]
I wasn't expecting sparks.
So Aric, right off,
up here on your blade,
you've taken some damage
on these serrations.
You lost a bit of this edge.
It's still in one piece.
You did a good job.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths.
It's time to find out how
sharp your blades are.
This is the sharpness
test, the jackfruit slice.
To find out how sharp
your weapons are,
I'm going to take your
weapon to cut the rope
and release this jackfruit.
Then I'm going to
slice through it.
Now unlike the
strength test, this
is all about what the
edge of your blade
does to the jackfruit.
Kevin, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
DOUG: Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Kevin, let's
talk about your edge here.
So the sweet spot that we
have right here for this sword
took a lot of damage
during the strength test.
So in the initial cut on
the rope, it didn't cut.
Now on the second cut, we
used a little bit other parts
of the blade where it is sharp.
It cut the rope and
it cut the jackfruit.
So overall, sir, your
weapon, it will cut.
- Good.
- All right, Aric.
Your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
Let's do it.
[music playing]
All right, Aric.
So it's the same thing.
The sweet spot on this
blade took some dulling
on the strength test.
It did affect cutting the
rope on the first attempt.
On the second attempt,
cut that rope and it
also cut the jackfruit in half.
Overall, sir, your
weapon, it will cut.
Excellent.
Well, gentlemen, we gave you
an extremely difficult blade
to build in the Tegha
sword, and you both
performed exceptionally
well in our tests.
But the judges have
made the decision,
and there can only
be one champion.
And the "Forged in Fire"
champion today is Aric.
Congratulations.
Kevin, unfortunately,
you didn't make the cut,
and Dave's going
to tell you why.
Kevin, what this
came down to was
the heat treat in that blade,
not getting it hard enough.
And so many of
those teeth just got
pounded back into that blade.
That's why we're letting you go.
OK.
Well, Kevin, you did
exceptionally well,
but unfortunately your time
in the forge has ended.
I'm going to have to ask
you to please step out.
That was probably
the most challenging
thing that I've ever done.
It had about half a dozen things
that I'd never done before.
I gave it my all, so
I'm pleased with what
I've brought to the table.
And I'm ready to get
back at it again.
Aric, congratulations.
You are today's "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Feeling pretty good?
I'm feeling amazing.
You definitely impressed us.
Good job, man.
Without further ado, there
is a check for $10,000
waiting for you out that door.
Go grab it.
Thank you.
I don't even know
how it happened.
Oh man.
That is, it's a surreal feeling.
Still hasn't even kicked in.
I recently got engaged.
So I will be putting the
$10,000 towards my wedding
and my honeymoon afterwards.
Love you, baby.
[music playing]